each class according to Hoover
Institution fellow david satter his new
book darkness at dawn finds a rampant
corruption in this transition from
totalitarian communism to democratic
capitalism the program's one-hour we all
know that after the terrorist attack on
September 11th the first person to offer
his condolences to the United States was
Vladimir Putin and one of the points
that Putin made was that Russians can
well understand the feelings of
Americans because they themselves were
the victims of a terrorist attack in
Russia he itself the terrorist attack
that he was referring to is well known
with the bombings of the apartment
buildings in Moscow Volga dansk and when
we knocks in September 1999 those
bombings were attributed to Chechens and
Chechen terrorists and be worthy pretext
for the launching of the second chechen
war war which continues to this day but
the question arises what if the
terrorist attack that Putin was
referring to was not carried out by
Chechens but on the contrary was carried
out by elements of the Russian
government itself under those
circumstances how do we evaluate the
professions of solidarity from the
Russian leadership and what does it mean
about the future of Russia itself the
book that I've written attempts to
describe the well-founded doubts about
the provenance of those bombings and to
show the evidence that in fact they were
carried out not by Chechens and not by
enemies of the state but rather by
agents of the state but to understand
how such a situation could have come
about it's necessary to take a detour
through the history of the last 12 years
because this was the period during which
Russia left totalitarianism and was
supposedly on its way to creating a
viable and prosperous democracy
it was the great hope of the United
States and it was a focus of American
foreign policy that such a development
would take place in fact their grave
doubts that said that that has happened
or will happen or will happen now or in
the near future the problem was and the
problem remains that Russia is a country
which is susceptible to ideas that in
itself is a positive thing but
inevitably there's a tendency in Russia
to choose the wrong ideas the wrong
ideas as we know were chosen in 1970
1917 with the result that a system of
enslavement was put in place in Russia
which lasted until 1991 but in 1991 when
Russia embarked on a new a new path and
in fact was in a position to break with
its previous tradition there was again a
problem of choosing the wrong ideas it
was held by the young reformers
so-called who enjoyed unstinting support
in the United States that all that was
really necessary was to take the
property that had been put in public
hands and put it in the hands of private
owners and that a law based democracy
would emerge automatically this was a
form of economic determinism which was
unconsciously inherited from the
communist regime the fact is as many of
you know or at least some of you may
know if you've bothered to read Marxist
philosophy that Marx held that the that
in order to have a socialist state it
was necessary to socialize the means of
production if property was in the hands
of the state you had socialism and if
you had socialism you had everything
else you had an end to class conflict
you had perfect equality you had
unlimited wealth it's an ironic that the
young reformers who provided the prided
themselves on being ardent enemies of
communism in a in attempting to
dismantle communism preserved
nonetheless communism principal Phyllis
co-principal the idea that it's the
economic system which determines the
structure of law and morality in society
rather than the other way around
and they single-mindedly began to pursue
the creation of capitalism in Russia
without law without morals and without a
framework of mutual obligation which is
necessary for a population undergoing
dramatic social change the first part of
the process was the marked by
hyperinflation in the Soviet Union there
was a system of administered prices all
prices were fixed but as a result of the
economic reforms instituted by Gorbachev
in 1985 inflationary pressures built up
in the Russian in the Soviet economy was
then the Soviet Union under conditions
of fixed prices inflation is reflected
in the shortage of goods and it was
impossible to buy anything in Russia in
the latter years of perestroika what it
was possible to buy some things the
stores for example had cabbages rotten
potatoes as the three year old fish
preserves and other things that that
people wouldn't buy and if they had any
choice but any desirable consumer in
items and including the most essential
were not available and the result was
that many money that people had earned
accumulated in savings accounts in 1990
to January 2nd prices were released in
Russia given the the amount of pent-up
inflation in the Russian economy this
prices skyrocketed with the result that
this that the life savings of virtually
the entire population was destroyed
people who had saved money for years to
buy an apartment a car to pay for a
wedding to pay for a funeral found that
they that that they had nothing left
that their savings was reduced to ashes
what had once been enough to buy an
apartment in 3-4 weeks
was enough to buy a pair of boots and
the result was that many people simply
were left in a helpless situation I was
living in Russia during that period and
one night there was a knock on the door
of my apartment and a woman said that
we're collecting money for the funeral
of a neighbor in the building people
literally had no money to be buried
I of course contributed but this was a
reflection of the state of Russia in
1992 in the wake of the release of of
prices and the hyperinflation
which wiped out the savings of an entire
generation and destroyed the the base of
mass support that had existed in Russia
for the economic reforms not everyone in
Russia however was impoverished by the
hyperinflation those who had made money
in the black market those who had
succeeded in accumulating money and
property as a result of the abuse of
their official positions and those who
had become involved in criminal
organizations were well placed to take
advantage of the inflation and to invest
their money continually in in in illegal
but nonetheless immensely profitable
currency exchanges and and businesses
which produced a high return because
they they could keep up with inflation
thus the first divide appeared in Russia
between the ultra rich and the
crushingly poor and that divide was to
widen over the years of the reforms in
Russia the Russian leadership under the
new reformers aware of the massive
discontent that was building up in the
society offered a scheme called voucher
privatization every Russian citizen was
entitled to a voucher which according to
the young reformers was good for two
Volga automobiles and represented each
citizens share of Russian industry in
fact the average Russian after 73 years
of
socialism had no idea what to do with
this voucher he didn't have a lot of
experience in investing in stock markets
voucher funds or anything else and a
series of mythical voucher funds
appeared in Russia which promised people
huge returns on their money and produced
very convincing advertisements which
showed with complex graphs how people's
vouchers would increase in value people
invested their monies money in these
funds and were informed that a mythical
Board of Directors somewhere had voted
that all returns from the voucher fund
had to be reinvested in short their
money disappeared those people who set
up these funds and those people who
organized the purchase of vouchers on
the street oftentimes in exchange for
bottles of vodka or even less were then
able to take their bags of vouchers
illegally acquired and used them to buy
up the first parts of Russian industry
voucher privatization was followed by
money privatization in 1994 it was no
longer possible to buy factories with
vouchers but you could buy them with
money but at this point the the nexus of
cooperation between corrupt officials
the newly rich and Russia's criminals
was such that no fair competition for
the purchase of Russia's industrial
enterprises was possible the the
auctions which existed and which were
announced often times were rigged to in
advance
the winner was pre predetermined with
the help of the local property
Commission in those cases where the
winner was not predetermined a
persistent bidder who succeeded in
buying an enterprise against the will of
the local property committee and the
criminal business group that was in one
way or another predestined
to acquire the enterprise often paid for
his persistence with his life finally in
late 95 this system had become more or
less institutionalized the rest of the
world became aware of the Russian
oligarchs these were people who had
succeeded in buying up Russian industry
using their connections and their wealth
to buy public officials in effect to
privatize the government it was commonly
understood that the most importance
starting capital for any Russian
enterprise was a purchased official
because that purchased official could
deliver the permission which allowed a
businessman to make land windfall
profits with those profits it was
possible to buy more officials and with
the the prophets which accrued as a
result of this subsequent purchase
purchases possible to buy even more
officials so the result was that the
government by 1995 in many respects
belonged to the super wealthy oligarchs
that the it itself had created and this
set the saith at the stage for what was
called the loans-for-shares program the
one flaw in this oligarchic system was
that it faced elections and in 1996
Yeltsin faced elections and his
popularity rating was only 7% there was
widespread fear that the Communists
would benefit from the anger on the part
of the population over the pillaging of
the country and that that Gennady
Zyuganov the head of the Communist Party
in Russia would be elected the new
president what happened was that an
agreement was reached between the newly
minted oligarchs and the the Yeltsin
government according to this agreement
the oligarchs would lend money to the
cash-strapped government cash-strapped
because of the effective of of massive
corruption on the state revenues and in
return the government would mortgage the
crown jewels of Russian industry to
those who made the loans if the
government was unable to pay on the
loans and it was a hundred percent
certainty that they wouldn't the
industrial enterprises would pass into
the hands of the oligarchs and that's
exactly what happened the oligarchs who
won the bidding were the people who
organized the bidding the government put
in charge of the bidding the very people
who were most interested in acquiring
the object being bid upon and the result
was that a huge percentage of Russian
industry fell into the hands of a very
very small group of people and it's now
true that in Russia the Russia has some
many of the wealthiest people in the
world although it's an impoverished
country and a large percentage according
to some estimates eighty five percent of
the Russian economy is one way or
another controlled by a small group of
Russian magnets none of whom had any
previous economic experience none of
whom created anything new all of whom
were successful in dividing up what
already existed the result for Russia
itself was catastrophic the in Russian a
cotton industrial production was cut in
half the death rate in Russia soared the
figures for mortality in Russia were so
frightening and so unbelievable that
Western demographers when they saw the
rate the the spiraling increase in the
rate of death in Russia did not believe
them at first they thought there'd been
a mistake only to find that the epidemic
of heart attacks strokes murder
suicide and fatal accidents was not a
mistake that it was in fact a real
reflection of the spiritual spiritual
economic and political crisis which was
affecting the country in any case the
Russian people afflicted with this
situation
turned once and for all against Yeltsin
in 1996 the flow of money from the Ella
gark senegalese scare campaign directed
against the communists not that the
Communists didn't deserve to be
campaigned against but the nature of the
campaign was intended to play on
people's fears and to and to induce them
to overlook the abuses of the Yeltsin
government had the effect of getting
Yeltsin elected in 1996 but as the
situation continued to get worse it was
clear to everyone there was no hope that
he that he or his hand-picked successor
was going to be elected in 2000 in 1998
an opinion polls showed two percent of
the population supported Yeltsin 2% now
in fact it's well known that in any
opinion poll six percent of the
respondents don't understand the
question so the two percent who
supported Yeltsin is not in it not only
not an impressive figure but it raises
the possibility but that no one in the
country actually supported him
and the the result was a wave of panic
in the Yeltsin leadership the situation
was made worse by the appointment of
Yevgeny Primakov as prime minister to
Yeltsin in the wake of an unsuccessful
attempt to impeach Yeltsin and a prima
coffee who enjoyed at least the the
grudging approval of the Communists and
the left-wing in Russia encouraged an
investigation by a man named Yuri
Skuratov the prosecutor general into the
corruption of the
yeltsin urine Skuratov said as he
proceeded in his investigation that
there's not a single person in the
yeltsin leadership who isn't guilty of
some crime that might seem like an
exaggeration to people here but i can
tell you it was no exaggeration in fact
it was an understatement he could have
gone into all the crimes they were that
they were guilty of but he did something
more than just rhetorically deal with
the problem he also began seriously to
investigate two of the most vulnerable
and prominent members of the yeltsin
entourage Boris Berezovsky and Pavel
Bure adine Berezovsky who is a car
dealer and who was close to Yeltsin's
family it he accumulated enormous wealth
most of it illegal pavel borodin was the
head of the kremlin property commission
he controlled and rented out and
administered all of the the the
government's property holdings in in
Russia and abroad and that was worth
billions of dollars both of them were
under investigation in Switzerland as
well as elsewhere and this investigation
threatened to unravel the whole skein of
corruption which had impoverished the
country and had created a system of
oligarchical power in Russia an
entrenched group that was allied with
criminals at the highest levels of state
power
however Yuri Skuratov had the bad
judgment to meet a couple of prostitutes
in a in a banya this is a Russian bath
that was run by one of Russia's largest
criminal organizations the salts of a
gang where he was photographed and the
photo and the film was shown on Russian
television at primetime well with a
brief war warning that this is not
suitable for children which of course
stopped no one from watching it for very
stop stopping yeah did not interfere
with anyone from from watching what what
happened and score in the aftermath
of this political pornography scre atif
was removed the person in charge of the
operation for the removal of Skuratov
was a little known at that time was
completely unknown head of the KGB RFS
be the successor organisations of the
KGB named Vladimir Putin a guy no one
had ever had ever heard of her ever
imagined could ever amount to anything
in Russia but he had obviously
recommended himself with this operation
because more was to be heard of him
later there began to be rumors in Moscow
that something terrible was going to
happen to save the Russian oligarchy and
the Yeltsin oligarchy the rumors were
were various that there would be
terrorist acts that there would be riots
no one was quite sure what but in August
of 1999 there was an explosion in the
Minesh shopping center which some of you
may know is near the Kremlin it's an
underground shopping center one person
was killed there was a haunting and
inexplicable invasion by a group of
Islamic extremists in from Chechnya of
the neighbouring province of Dagestan
this was treated as aggression against
Russia because at that time Chechnya had
won at least a provisional independence
from Russia but there were many puzzling
things about this invasion for one thing
the border guards who normally guarded
the border between Chechnya and Dagestan
shortly before the invasion were removed
secondly the Russian army and Air Force
made no effort to stop the invaders they
were beaten back by the local police and
when they left
Dagestan after this so-called invasion
no one tried to pursue them they left in
columns of trucks and there was no
effort
on the part of the Russian garrison in
the area to stop them harassed them
interdict them in any way
all of which gave rise to the
possibility that this invasion had been
staged in order to provide a pretext for
an invasion of Chechnya but a terrorist
act in Moscow in which one person is
killed and a comic opera invasion of
Dagestan which is over in a couple of
weeks would not have been enough to
rally the Russian people behind a new
war in Chechnya the but what happened
next
definitely did beginning in early
September apartment buildings were blown
up in the middle of the night in Russian
cities killing all of the inhabitants
the climax took place in Moscow with the
with the blowing up of the apartment
buildings on in gory aanava' street and
the kosher skaia chassé hundreds of
people were killed men women and
children blown to bits crushed under the
falling masonry and bricks while they
slept and the the the the result was
that the Russian public was galvanized
behind a new war in Chechnya Vladimir
Putin who weeks days before had been
named the new Prime Minister took charge
of this new war and at first it went
well largely because the northern part
of Chechnya is a plane up to the Terek
River no real resistance against a
Regular Army as possible
in the event of an invasion of that area
and for a Russian public weary of
impoverishment frustrated by the
hardships of life xenophobic resentful
of the loss of power angry at the
Chechens for the defeat that they
administered to the Russians in 90
96 a perfect foil was created for all of
the frustration that had built up in
Russia and the anger that had been
directed against the Yeltsin entourage
was redirected against the Chechens and
Vladimir Putin whom no one had ever
heard of who had never run for office
who is totally unprepossessing and whose
entire career virtually had been spent
in the security services became a
national hero overnight the result was
that his popularity went up 20% 30% 40%
by Yeltsin resigned at the in the end of
December 1999 and Putin became the
Acting President that meant there were
three months to hold new presidential
elections though during those three
months the war in Chechnya was still
going relatively well Putin was
reelected and his first official act was
to issue a pardon for for Yeltsin and
the members of his family for all crimes
committed during his time in office and
that pardon was extremely sweeping it
protected Yeltsin against searches of
his home his telephone records his car
his apartment and also and extended the
same protection to his relatives who
were in fact the core of corruption in
Russia and guilt Putin was welcomed as a
great leader in the West and the Russian
people themselves reacted positively to
his decisiveness or his appearance of
decisiveness and all would have been
very successful had it not been for one
mistake as often happens in life nothing
is carried out perfectly and that was
the case with what I think was the
conspiracy to put a hand-picked
successor to Yeltsin into power and to
preserve the division of property
because there was another bombing and
that was in the city of Ria's on there
was another bomb and that was placed in
in a basement
of an apartment building in Ria's on but
this bomb didn't go off
an attentive neighbor an attentive
resident of the building saw people
putting the bomb saw people doing
something suspicious and with the whole
country in a state of terror over the
bombing of apartment buildings he called
the police the police did not want to
come he insisted they came he forced
them to go down into the basement which
local drunks had used as a toilet police
didn't want to go down there then this
resident of the building forced them to
he and his daughter forced them to go
down there they went down into the
basement bolted up the steps I said
there's a bomb in there and evacuated
the building the neighboring buildings
and finally the entire district
thousands of people were out on the
street the bomb squad in Ryazan went
down to into the building to tested it
and tested the test of the materials
which tested positive for hexagons the
explosive used in all the other bombings
the Obama experts also identified the
detonator it was a real live military
detonator capable of detonating the bomb
and destroying the building not only
that the building was built on it on a
hill and had the bomb gone off the force
of the explosion would have obliterated
the building the building would have hit
the next building down the slope with
the force of an avalanche and taken it
out - as a result the casualties would
have been more terrible than four for
all of the previous bombings combined
the immediately a dragnet was announced
for Ria's on the city was literally
sealed off all roads were closed Airport
was closed train stations were closed
all the police were called up there were
announcements on all the media because
there was a description of the three
people who had placed the bomb and
sometime during that day a telephone
call was made from the Interurban
phone station and an attentive phone
operator listened in on the call I said
that this is an old Russian habit but my
wife who's Russian it isn't like that so
I I won't say that that's a Russian
habit I'll say that that's a tendency of
anyone under circumstances in which
people are panicked she listened to the
call and the caller said they've got the
city surrounded how do we get out of
here the voice on the other lines had
split up and get out any way you can she
traced the call gave the number to the
local police they called they checked
the number expecting it to be the number
of Chechen terrorists it was the number
of the FSB at that not long after that
the three terrorists were arrested they
produced FSB identification it was now
clear that the failed bombing could not
be attributed to Chechens anymore
and Nikolai patrushev the head of the
FSB got on national television and said
congratulations to the residents of
Ria's on this was a test of vigilance
and you did brilliantly now actually I
want to take my book and read to you the
most appropriate what I feel are the
most is are the most appropriate most
appropriate way to react to that claim
which is this one can't believe
impossible things I daresay you haven't
had much practice said the Queen when I
was your age I always did it for half an
hour a day why sometimes I believed as
many as six impossible things before
breakfast
that's from Alice in Wonderland and if
you want to believe six impossible
things before breakfast you can believe
that that was a training exercise in a
country which was already in a state of
total terror and in which the false
calls about bombs were coming in by the
dozens all over the country but if it
wasn't a training exercise what was it
because if it was an attempt to blow up
the building and if it was the FSB that
was responsible for doing so and if the
modus operandi is exactly the same as
that that was used in the buildings that
were blown up that suggests that it was
the FSB which is it generally speaking a
blunt instrument for those who are in
power that was responsible for the
terrorist act that killed 300 Russians
as they slept and served as the
justification for the second chechen war
war which has caused thousands of deaths
and is still going on the the book that
I wrote attempts to describe this
history and it attempts to show the
consequences for Russia of choosing that
wrong idea once again ie that you can
transform economic structures and you
can create a democratic society without
the benefit of a framework of law or
morality it's a it's a Mis it's a Mis
apprehension which is common to the
modern age because we all forget
oftentimes the invisible framework of
morality which was bequeathed to us by
our political system founded centuries
ago by people influenced by the
Enlightenment in a country like Russia
which didn't have that historical
experience we all too often assume that
the same framework of morality and law
exists there that exists here or exists
in the West when in reality it's
precisely that that has to be created
it was the mistake I think of
policymakers in the United States to
ignore this fundamental aspect of
Russian reform and the consequences for
Russia now are that the country faces a
very uncertain future because under
these circumstances insofar as it was
the FSB which apparently saved the Oleg
Archy it is now the FSB which dominates
the Russian system and the FSB the
inheritor to the KGB which was
responsible for such terror in Russia
cannot be the agent of democratization
in Russian society as a result the
future of Russia once again is in
question and once again Russia faces the
same that's the same dilemma that it is
faced throughout its modern history
which is where is the source of values
is the source of values in the economic
system is there any economic system
which in and of itself can generate
values or does an economic situation by
its nature require the guidance of
values I think that was the false answer
to that question which created the
present criminal ascendancy in Russia
and makes Russia a danger not only to
itself but to the rest of the world as
well because it's instability could
ultimately threaten us and it's it's
this realization that is it needs to be
brought home to Russians and Americans
and is in reality I think the only real
hope for Russia's future future
resurrection and with that I will I will
close these extended remarks and if I
answer your questions if you have any
everyone is standing people can come up
and take seats their seats in the front
row their seats all along here if you
want to sit down don't have to sit down
and we're gonna ask people who want to
ask questions to please use the
speaker's mic right here
it was a marvelous presentation David it
held us all and thrall and I'm sure
there are lots of questions
they're also seats here and there all
there's so many people standing in front
there's all right we won't we won't do
what Hans Morgenthau used to do when I
was a student forced people to come yeah
sets of values and all that sort of
thing and I think it does have a very
clear role but there's also the issue of
laws and and and and the is it were not
working it's the the question of the
competitiveness and the and the
permission to be competitiveness that
could be can be competitive and the
doors that allow competition as well as
the system of value so I think there's
both the legal side and these and the
innate values that that go behind it
well I did everyone hear the question do
you mind if I repeat your your question
the questioner was saying that this the
question of values but there's also the
question of law that regulates
competition and that makes it possible
for there to be competition but what is
I think the real question then is what
is the source of law the source of law
is values and in fact the law replicates
in its application and in its existence
the religious values of the West because
the position the Equality of the
citizens before the law is simply a
reproduction of the supposed equality of
believers before God the system of law
which presumes that equality in
incarnate in fact the presumption of the
religious turn religious moral truth
that all are equal before God and so
when we talk about the laws that
regulate competition we are talking
about the influence via those laws of
values in the society and it's only when
you think that the economic system
established on its own is capable of
generating the practices independent of
any moral agency that will control its
functioning that you create monsters
like the Soviet Union or the criminal
ascendancy that exists in Russia today
what's your solution well yeah that's
that's this is a very American question
but the yeah for the sake of all who
wanted to ask the same question I'll try
to to to answer it this solution is the
creation in Russia of a critical mass of
in the population that is determined to
organize politically and recognize the
importance of doing away once and for
all with the criminals who have taken
over the country that may seem difficult
in fact it's not there's abundant
information on the criminal activities
of all of the leading Russian oligarchs
partially this is because law
enforcement has collected this
information and it's it's they are not
acted upon but also it's the fact that
each of the oligarchs has been very busy
collecting information on the other one
on the others and has made it perf
is more than willing to make this
information available to law enforcement
Russia faces a systemic crisis the
population is declining and declining
catastrophically and no one should be
fooled by the appearance of he cannot
have relative economic well-being this
is tied to the
price of oil if the price of oil Falls
Russia's will quickly slip into economic
crisis under these circumstances and
given the fact that this is a country
with the lowest male life expectancy in
the industrial world there are enormous
pressures on the society to take its
fate in its own hands that can only be
done politically but it's important to
bear in mind that there's a real
political vacuum in Russia that an
honest person could well fill and as
long as there are semi democratic
institutions and as long as there is
awareness and that the point about
awareness is very important there's a
chance that Russia through its own
devices can establish the the type of
democracy and and make the type of
changes which will allow the country to
breathe free it from the yoke of those
who are strangling it in fact and make
it possible for the country to have a
better future
but one of the the role that the United
States and the West can play in all this
and since we are not direct actors is by
making it clear to the Russians that we
understand the nature of the problem and
by elucidating it ourselves in this
respect I might my greatest hope is that
what I've written will make a difference
because it is going to be published very
soon in Russia and when I was that one
of the people whose red red darkness
adorned his grigory yavlinsky he's the
head of a political party in Russia who
intends to use the book in the
pre-election camp in the election
campaign for the Russian parliament in
December in any case you know the truth
shall make you free and and awareness
and political organization on the part
of the population could well provide the
preconditions for doing something about
the egregious conditions that exists
there and dealing with that with with
with bringing justice to to the victims
of the terror bombings of 1999 which
were as traumatic for Russia work as as
September 11th was for us we had the
benefit of being victims of bombings
carried out not by our own government
it will be of course much more traumatic
in Russia if the truth leads to the
Russian government but it's a truth that
needs to be told
yeah my name is Nikolai Simon I'm afraid
does not left working
my name is Nikolai Simon I am
correspondent for Russian weekly
magazine eat Oggy
oh yeah and first I have to make a very
short comment among Russians so called
all the guards the normal was first
employed by mr. Chapuys was at least one
who created Samson
I mean mister I mean mr. Kosinski with
his MTV and newspaper savonia magazine
otoki and with TV program seven days but
I would like to hear from you the
comment about very funny situations
which somehow is related to the subject
of your book I'm sure you remember this
noisy scandal about New York bank during
I think six months all newspapers
including Wall Street Journal New York
Times Financial Times were filled with
the new revelations about money
laundering from Russia and where were
true very small trial and three people's
was given some kind of jail but it was
so unprecedented the quiet when the in
the beginning but this with ear those
scandal was closed the Manhattan
attorney closed the deal and nobody
the Information Agency some information
agencies presented this fact so I would
like to hear your comment about this you
know disproportional the coverage yes
well first of all first first of all I
stand corrected GU since ki did create
something and in light of all the money
that he he managed to appropriate
without creating it's good he did create
something and NTV was certainly worth
creating not to mention he togi also
worth creating as far as the Bank of New
York scandal after it's surfaced I have
to confess to you that I didn't follow
its further development I know that that
that the prosecution of the case petered
out for whatever reason but the fact
that without yeah III do cite in the
book and I do know of other cases in
which promising investigations petered
out because of a lack of cooperation
from the Russian authorities I don't
know if that's the case in the Bank of
New York scandal I haven't followed the
latest developments in it but whether
that scandal was overblown or not the
fact of illegal capital export and money
laundering in Russia is undeniable and I
wouldn't want to draw too broad a
conclusion from the fate of that one
scandal especially when I haven't seen
the conclusions of the prosecutor the
Ministry of Internal Affairs in Russia
estimated that the amount of capital
illegally removed from Russia was close
to 200 billion dollars in the reform
period so whether the four billion in
the case of the Bank of New York was was
overblown or not the phenomenon exists
Sattar what you described is just
absolutely awful you know far worse than
anything that I had imagined and I think
I read the paper fairly closely as
probably many people do and such a
despotic criminal state and it's you
know it's not just a matter of
unfairness I mean this is a matter of
I've seen some of the life expectancy
figures too and it's absolutely horrible
and awful and if there was any kind of
government there they did they would
attend to this incredible public health
crisis that's going on now what about
and your your title - I mean darkness at
dawn you know it's been snuffed out even
before it began as far as I can tell in
my studying of Russian history a reading
of Russian history and and Soviet
history you know if we're just looking
at the 20th century the people that have
gotten to power you know a few
mensheviks in 1917 and maybe Mikhail
Gorbachev which I don't know maybe you
could you could you know shatter our
illusions about him but at least you
know he was a communist but at least he
seemed to be of some you know reformist
you know mode you know unquestionably
you know where's the history where is
the who has ever it where is the the
basis for hope in this society with all
of these tremendous needs well first of
all I don't agree that Russia is
despotic at the present time it's
corrupt it's dangerous it's a country
which faces a systemic crisis but in
fact compared to the Soviet Union for
the it's important to bear in mind
Russia is relatively free and it does
have some very worthwhile institutions I
mean the mere fact that a book like this
can be published in Russia that tells
you something just just in and of itself
but it's it's a different kind of
misgovernment and oppression it's
government that's not so much concerned
with total political control and turning
people into into zombies the way the
communists were it just doesn't want to
be challenged so that the people around
the government can will be free to
enrich themselves at the expense of
everyone else but the deeper question of
Russia's fate and why Russia
consistently turns out bad leaders and
bad governments as far as Gorbachev is
concerned he wasn't he was no angel but
of course he perhaps inadvertently
played an enormous lead positive
historical role it's a part of the
misconception in Russia that shared
really around around the world by by
various people that it's possible to
find values from something other than a
transcend a genuinely transcendent
source religious and political power in
Russia were so amalgamated the state was
so deified and its prerogatives so
deified that individuals were degraded
in fact any time a system absolute Isis
itself individuals become
interchangeable and the de fication and
the state in Russia the degradation and
the individual created a situation in
which people couldn't imagine values
which transcended the state and to which
the state was also subject and that
tradition the idea that the individual
human being compared to the wielders of
power is worth nothing and that his life
is worth nothing that that persists and
Russia will have know that one of the
chapters in the book is the value of
human life and Russia will not move
forward will not be able to save itself
until that conception of the individual
is changed till people understand that
the individual does have value
there's one incident in the well serfdom
was was one reflection of it but there
were many factors there was as this was
the inheritance of Byzantium and the
Mongol domination of Russia serfdom
actually ended up post-dated you know
some of some of this development but in
any case that is the there's a one
incident in the book about a little boy
who is killed in a motor accident when
Putin's motorcade drove into the into a
lane of oncoming traffic outside of
Moscow hit the car in which the little
boy was riding and then he was killed
and there was no justice for that child
and the no justice for the family and
the Putin's hangers-on tried to cover it
all up now Putin himself was not driving
the car so he cannot eat he was his
driver who was responsible but his
driver was protected and it's absolutely
common for Russian leaders at various
ranks to kill people with their crazy
driving habits because they don't see
those people as they as being as having
lives that ought to be protected and
there are worth something in this
psychology is reflected I believe in
what happened in Moscow in 1999 after
all it's very possible to imagine the
logic of someone who said who treats
individuals as having no importance as
saying well ok 300 people or 800 people
will be blown up but our hold on power
will be preserved that's how the
Bolsheviks thought and that strain of
thinking hasn't disappeared from Russia
is any anyone else yeah I have to which
one this probably both of them but
they're ok I have two questions first
question given the Soviet Russian
history and Soviet history and
especially
there do you ever see the possibility of
other developments this is the 90s after
years since coming to power the other
way of developing the situation and the
second equation you describe very
vividly and I completely agree with your
description of collapse of structures of
government law and power in Russia in
90s and don't you see that basically
that FSB or KGB a former it was
basically the one the stabilizing power
that left in the society at this time
and I also agreed probably it was
participating and crimes you mentioned
but on the other hand what are the force
you could see in Russia capable of
maintaining the state thank you I may
have to repeat your question I'm not
sure everyone heard you if they did not
tell me I'll try to paraphrase what you
said I think the first is could there
have been another development aside from
the Yeltsin evolution during the 1990s
and was not the KGB you know for all its
faults a stabilizing factor in Russia
and one of the few structures capable of
exerting a stabilizing influence is that
okay is that yeah more or less right
well let's take the second question
first the FSB which is the organization
which succeeded the KGB cannot be a
stabilizing influence in in Russia
because more and more it's involved in
Russia's criminal activities the FSB a
now has a whole network of private
security organizations which offer
protection to business at a price that
means that they in addition to other
Russian law enforcement organizations
have gone into the protection racket and
they've treating protection and
extortion is a normal part of life the
only thing that can stabilize the
situation in Russia is the rule of law
and you know the fact that it got a
bunch of enforcers have joy you exist
and work hand in glove with the corrupt
holders of wealth can't be a stabilizing
factor in the society only if those are
forces are enforcing something that's
reasonable and that is the impartial
application of the law which they're not
doing and certainly they're not doing if
my suspicions are correct about the
terrorist acts of 1999 now as far as the
could the Yeltsin evolution have been
different I think there are two
questions there first of all could
Yeltsin have been different or and
second of all could there have been
someone other than Yeltsin Yeltsin was
certainly influenced enormous ly by the
United States and by the West had if the
advice had been better could he have
been better possibly he was not an
experienced international politician
could someone else have emerged as
Russian leader during that period well
that goes back to the question of the
perestroika years and as it happened
Andrei Sakharov died in 1989 of a heart
attack had Sakharov lived he would not
have been president of Russia
unfortunately but he would have had
great influence and his his under those
circumstances perhaps it might have been
someone different than Yeltsin someone
more worthy maybe even someone like
Alexander Yakovlev but that's historical
speculation
by very gracious fortune the Fulbright
Scholars are going to be sent to Russia
this year there was some perhaps some
concern and anxiety that they wouldn't
be I'll be going to st. Petersburg next
March to May as I said to you before the
I'm terrorized of going and I'll tell
you what I'm anxious about and I'd like
to find out what what your advice is
about how I can be a better ambassador
informal ambassador just as your book is
a kind of ambassadorship - I think I'm
yes very concerned about the criminal
element and what that means but more
importantly I'm afraid I'm gonna get
overwhelmingly depressed there if
there's a sense of hopelessness or a
sense of hysteria so what has been your
experience and what what can I do well
as far as your personal experience is
concerned I think you'll probably have a
great personal experience in Russia
because Russia is full of interesting
people
they are very hospitable and very
friendly and despite the government's
anti-americanism at the present they
like Americans and are very tolerant and
I think that you'll have a great time in
that respect if you don't wish to you
can ignore the conditions in Russia and
associate with people who will not
remind you whose whose way of life will
not remind you of the hardships of the
society the hardships of societies going
through so if you want to be well
informed as well as to have a good time
then it's up to you really to ask people
what's going on and to and to try to to
look beneath the surface of events there
this is a big problem for a lot of
Western observers
that they don't do that and Russians are
not going to just tell you everything
about their lives and about the lives of
others you have to take an active
interest but if you do that you'll be
rewarded for first of all intellectually
and Zsasz insofar as you'll understand
the country better and second of all I
think you'll you'll you'll be rewarded
by the respect of your Russian
interlocutors who both like and admire
Westerners who really try to understand
what is going on in the country and take
it as a sign of respect so I would not
be afraid and I would just go there with
the anticipation that you'll meet lots
of interesting people and with the
determination to take advantage of their
knowledge so that you can be better
informed and can tell people back here
about what's really going on in that
great country David Satter is a research
fellow at Stanford University's Hoover
Institution darkness at dawn is
published by Yale University Press on
the web at Yale Books calm